and what I recommend with all these
types of problems is just a draw a
sketch so if you draw a sketch sometimes
it will help you to figure out the other
pieces of the puzzle so let's go ahead
and do that so first thing we have is
okay we've got a coordinate axis and we
know our full-size are at two okay plus
or minus 2 root 5 comma 2 so we know
we're going to be going up to here okay
that's the y-value but then we're going
to be going to route 5 to the right ok
and we're gonna be going to route 5 to
the left those are the full sigh okay
and this is the center ok so you can see
the center is going to be at 2 comma 2
okay because it's halfway in between the
full sigh and we know that our hyperbola
is going to look something like this and
like this approximately okay so now
let's put together what we know so far
so we know that X minus 2 squared plus
minus 4 hyperbolas plus 4 ellipses Y
minus 2 squared equals 1 okay so we've
got our Center 2 to the x squared term
is the positive term that comes first
when it's opening left and right if the
hyperbola is opening up and down then
the y squared term would come first
okay sorry with me so far and then what
we're trying to do now is we're trying
to find the denominators okay the a
squared and the B squared okay now we
look at our asymptotes here and we can
notice that the slope is 2 and plus or
minus 2 over 1 anything divided by 1 is
itself and we know that the ratio of the
quantity that's underneath the Y term
divided by the X term is going to be the
slope of the asymptote so this is going
to be the rise and this is going to be
the run now if these terms were reversed
then we want to take the term that here
ok the one that's underneath the Y value
divided by the one underneath the x
value so what we're going to do here is
we're going to say alright this is a
squared this is B squared we want to do
B divided by a B divided by a equals
we're just going to do two okay for
right now so
if I solve for B by cross-multiplying I
get B equals 2a alright and we know with
hyperbolas C squared equals a squared
plus B squared just like Pythagorean
theorem right ok we know that C is the
distance from the center to the full
side that's C ok and we know that C is 2
square root 5 so we have to square root
5 squared equals a squared plus okay and
B equals 2 times a so this is going to
be 2 times a squared okay so here with
me so far so if we Square this we're
going to get 2 squared is 4 square root
of 5 squared is 5 so this comes out to
20 equals a squared plus 4a squared
because 2a times 2a this gives us 5 a
squared equals 20 divided by 5 and we
can see that a squared equals 4 or you
could say a equals 2 now if we put 2
back in here you can see that B is going
to equal 4 so if we substitute those
values back in if a is 2 x squared would
be 4 so let's just cross this out this
is 4 and B squared is going to be 4
squared which is 16 so those